the fact that like podcast Clips are so
boring now that you have to have a
[__] Subway Surfer thing at the
bottom just otherwise I can't watch it
wouldn't that become like a meta for
like I did a video and someone
re-uploaded the entire thing to tiktok
but they put rocket League highlights
below it and it got 20 million views
welcome to another episode of trash
taste I'm Conor once again I'm joined by
the boys Joey and gone and today we have
a very special guest laser beam good day
how's it going do you like being
referred to as a laser Beaver uh battle
Lenin
however you want to do it
um I had a substitute teacher called me
langwin as a kid
I don't know where she got the G from
um a bit worrying if your substitute
teacher can't read
I feel like pretty sure langlin's not
even a real name either some people
would say lannin's not a real name you
know I've never met someone with that as
a first name that's true it's okay A lot
of people think gaunt is in the real
name which it probably isn't but yeah
it's not really it is it is if you
believe it is yeah in my entire life has
just been a mispronunciation of my name
but I I remember at one point I was like
the only gun on Facebook like as a first
name because uh so reflex yeah yeah
that's how I know the name's rare So
unless you type it out Lennon's on
Facebook uh no so it's like a weirdly
enough it's like a last name that some
people have like spelled the exact way a
lot of people have Lenin
but which is like l-a-n-n-o-n or
whatever but my I was named after the
beetle
um but but misspelled differently yeah
my dad's like specifically I want my son
to have a hard time at school
well look at me like [__] this kid you
know he wanted to be he wanted the girl
uh and he was like ah [__] another boy
because he's like my favorite Beatle
John Landon
he's also like one of the most
questionable of The Beatles
yeah it could have been ringer so so
anyone who doesn't know you who's
watching this do you want to maybe just
give a brief little uh explanation oh
God that's the background
um
how do you summarize yourself uh I
played a little Fortnight I make YouTube
videos some people like them some people
don't get a little hate comments well
that's good you also get a ridiculous
amount of views on your video so it's
sometimes sometimes but um yeah
only five million views I fell off ah I
do say that oh my god oh bro I wish man
I wish yeah you know one day one day
maybe take Fortnight was a different
breed
um yeah no I've been doing it eight
years eight and a half years uh started
smashing things with machines that was
my first channel wait what and then uh
there's a long story
how do we go from fortnite so yes well I
started yes well I was a I was a
construction worker so oh [__] wow
I was bored and I didn't want to do I
didn't want to be a concreter forever so
I'm like [__] it I'll make videos
because I watched a lot of Machinima
yeah
at this point oh when I when I I was 19
I think yeah
yeah 19.
um sort of just realized didn't want to
do construction forever yeah yeah I was
like oh well there's enough Gamers out
there there's enough people doing that
[__] so I'll do something different so I
just was trying to think what do I have
that other people wouldn't have right
and access to likely I know how to drive
an excavator I know how to drive a
Bobcat so after work I just like set up
a microwave like swing around like I'm
playing t-ball with an excavator I was
like a budget slo-mo guys
well I know I bought a slow-mo camera
but it was like a really [__] one so I
was like and this was like yeah like
almost 10 years ago nine years ago or
whatever so I was like yeah
it's like 360 pay and she was really bad
it's not funny
um after six months of doing that I had
60 subs and then all my camera gear got
stolen oh oh [__] I was in a regional
Country Town lots of crime
um and that's what I was like [__] I
might as well do gaming all I had left
with my laptop so that came full circle
you're like [__] this game as well it
was more like I have no choice now I
can't replace this like five grand the
camera gear that was my wife saying
did you like they broke in and uh yeah
it's still unsolved mystery so if anyone
knows anyone has any tip-offs I look at
you you sounded so like like they can
just take things no no I mean I mean I'm
just like I mean I'm just like how did
it like that's a lot of equipment you
can't just like it's not like you can
just pickpocket that you know uh well
yeah it was just overnight they just
break in take it it was wasn't the
nicest area that I was operating in
right but um
well cops just don't really give a [__]
they're like that's five grand stuff
like hopefully your insurance will cover
it in two years wait did they take
anything else aside from the camera
um I don't remember what they it was
just like a lot of camera gear that's
all it really was bro this was a [__]
hit Joe quite literally like it was in a
box like sitting like right there yeah
so as soon as they get in it's like
right there it's like [__] easy
um let's look for easy targets but um
yeah enough I had no choice to do gaming
at that point yeah I was like yeah
like what if if all of my gear got
stolen I don't think I'd want to make
videos anymore oh I cried I would be
honest I was a grown man I was crying it
was like a buff treaty at that point but
I was tears Mars and I thought my dream
was dead I was like that's this was all
my savings was on this like this was my
dream was YouTube your full-time job
back then or no not at this point
oh 60s
oh my God you had 60 Subs yeah 5K worth
well that was like my savings I was like
bro I was still living with my parents
so I was like didn't have any costs so
it was either like
getting on the pistol and drugs or by
camera gear you know so yeah I was like
well I don't want to be a drop kick so
I'll do I'll Chase my dreams instead of
doing all my friends was it easy to kind
of pick up gaming and and making videos
about that or was it about I always
loved gaming like I was a massive nerd
um yeah yeah so I was already but I just
didn't think was realistic because it
was you know even people to this day oh
it's too saturated you can't do it if
you think it's realistic odds are you're
probably way too overconfident yeah
massively but um I started out doing
like American Sports like Madden okay I
had like a I was like the Australian kid
that loved American Sports and that was
another way to be different I used to
share it on Reddit put my first videos
on Reddit
um but Aussie reviews but well I kind of
just did really dumb [__] like everyone
was playing the game super seriously
they're like competitive they do these
series whatever I was like okay take the
fattest dude in the game can you score a
touchdown
I sit there for 12 hours trying to score
until like the game glitched in some way
it's a week at school and then I put it
on Reddit and everyone loved it yeah
sitting there saying like oh [__] yeah
[__] [__] yeah because I was fresh off
the job site and then
yeah so like instantly as soon as I was
doing gaming within like three months I
had like 50k Subs it was like oh [__] I
should dance from stuff was that like
variety at that point or was it no it
was just it was just like American
Sports like basketball Madden I think it
was a year in I started doing like [__]
well but I think you already like
pinpointed the niche of just like you
know not doing what everyone else was
exactly like that's where it is also an
Aussie playing American how did you get
into American Sports I grew up playing
baseball right whatever reason
um in Australia yeah I was I was [__]
how
really enough where I grew up uh uh I've
never even seen this field in Australia
surprise like so Sydney does decent um I
was on the Central Coast so like two
hours north of Sydney whatever reason my
cousin was playing it
um he'd later go on to play in America
so did my brother oh wow you know
reasonably good genetics in the family
but not for me not for me I was dog [__]
but it did mean my eyes were sort of
open to you know foreign sport right one
day I happened to see a Family Guy
episode oh yeah uh and had Tom Brady in
it uh which I don't know he's he's my
guy he's my guy okay okay
um and whatever reason I just remember
that so one day I was just any EB Games
yeah so mad and I was like oh [__] I'll
try it yeah bless
[__] yeah
um but yeah I was just like yeah no one
else plays this game the way I would and
I kind of took that energy and saw the
success from that like when I started
doing indie games and everything same
kind of thing when I started doing
fortnite
same kind of thing I feel like I saw it
slightly differently right not that was
revolutionary but I definitely saw it
slightly differently it was it mainly
like when you're growing up was it
mainly just sports games you were
playing or just like a little bit of
everything oh bro I was a [__] nerd
bro you're on a podcast foreign
they took my entire childhood years and
I was bullied relentlessly for it yeah
um I'd never leave the house uh I mean
look I did the Call of Duties I did the
fifas I did all that yeah a lot of Age
of Empires like Total War series like
all the strategy nerdy [__] yeah but
yeah I don't even think that's that
nerdy maybe up in a place where I'm just
like yeah so I got so bullied for that
[__] it was a nerdy that sounds cool to
me man yeah I think it's cool yeah yeah
that's awful I'm sorry I'm so excited I
missed the whole RuneScape kind of like
earrings not too late it's not too late
oh yeah yeah I did play it like once for
like a stream and then it was it was a
lot of fun although I would say we
played it with like a what is it like
not a multiplier but like an accelerator
right so we did like a promotion with
RuneScape and they had a server that was
like times 50 XP oh that'd be nice
suddenly came sort of realization I was
like I'm having a lot of fun but if I
just played this at normal speed how
long would it take to get through all
the content I took I did in that four
hours I mean after that I went and
played on the the time 50 server a
little bit more and I was grinding
levels I was like oh my God this is so
slow yeah now as soon as you go back to
the normal game it's awful but it's it's
weird because the kind of game that you
play where you're doing all this [__]
yeah that's right everyone who tells
yeah who's played it does that they're
like I'm doing something else I just
keep clicking it while I'm doing the
other thing yeah it's such a weird
experience because you're playing it but
you hate playing it because it's such a
grind
but you just when you get like a level
or a 99 or a big dress like MMOs
I mean at least wow you're playing the
goddamn game I feel like when you're you
literally click and then don't click for
another like 30 seconds you
can try and come back click once every
20 minutes yeah what are you doing
like where's that a game at that point
but like I love it it kind of sounds
like a gotcha game to me yeah like
it's just taking like like it was one of
the OG like grind mechanics game yeah
yeah and then obviously gacha took took
a lot of inspiration from those type of
games like Cookie Clicker and all those
games yeah we don't [__] click
anything you know just let it sit yeah
yeah you just you just click every now
and then and then you're like all right
I'm just gonna leave it for 10 years I'm
Gonna Leave the [__] quick clicker on
I hate those games I I always just get
like I'd always start Cookie Clicker and
then I just hack it just do inspect
element and change it
yeah
he's changed one value like you beat the
game but you don't get the gratification
of the clicking yeah but that's actually
the point of beating Cookie Clicker
there is no point right now I don't
remember I don't think it doesn't it's
just like a it's like just to say
dopamine bandage yeah yeah I think
that's why like I found myself actually
kind of obsessing with it for like a
three hour period And so I'm like okay
I'm gonna hack and hack this and ruin it
for myself it's like when you cheat in a
game yeah if you're cheating a game it
ruins the game yeah always so like you
don't want to play it anymore it's like
a way to solve yourself from being
addicted like if you if you play WoW or
something you just buy not so much in
WoW but like you buy all the gold you
buy all the gear yeah all after 10
minutes because there's nothing to
achieve right yeah so like yes and then
you move on you break that addiction
yeah it's all it's all about the journey
right if you don't put effort in you
don't feel like the gratification of
actually getting the items and actually
getting like the power that you worked
for which is like kind of like I guess
Why Pay to Win games is a complete broke
in the system now you know yeah yeah so
even in those you can't even pay enough
there's always like they slowly like
diminishing return it to the point that
you're dropping thousands and you still
can't quite always win yeah yeah so what
what after the American kind of like
gaming phase that you went through in
YouTube what what came up for that uh
did lots of indie games
um you know like everyone breaking it
was that so obviously breaking it as
much as possible oh yeah ideally like
lots of mods and stuff I like kind of
what everyone was doing at that point
like that was the biggest thing was like
the jacksepticeye's the even PewDiePie
at that point everyone was sort of just
doing indie games obviously people were
successful in Minecraft cool do whatever
but I still think the biggest games at
the time were definitely like playing
random games then I kind of started
doing reactions for a bit like I just
would look at Reddit and be like
150 200k video that's not bad did that
for a couple years but the issue was it
was good then add apocalypse happens and
the problem is when you're saying all
the naughty words because you're
Australian
start you stop making money so
you're you're having to they're applying
American ad standards on yeah yeah yeah
UK and Australia who notoriously swear a
lot more than Americans the c word is so
easy to say it's not even I didn't even
say a c words just because the fact that
like you know how some people say like
um yeah like that's [__] for me I say
[__] um as well but it's with [__] in
there as well yeah it's like a sandwich
of it so it meant that like every third
word in the video was just [__]
and especially the reactions and like I
I was probably a bit edgy at the time
where I'd show clips of like dumb [__]
happening yeah no I'm dying
no so I did the Reddit 50 50 videos
but like you could kind of probably
still anyway yeah like you could maybe
see some [__] [__] I don't know but I
deleted this
um but yeah I feel like
I just 2016 and pray YouTube was such a
different place so I was still kind of
existing like that yeah the whole back
catalog and then at apocalypse happens
so somehow like fortnite family friendly
yeah you know it's especially the first
year of fortnite still swear a little
bit but I definitely tried to be a
little bit more intelligent with how did
you get like a lot of parents you mean
like you got to stop swearing oh all the
time no my favorite one it's my big it's
the such it's not even that much of a
swear word but my favorite one is
um it was Peak covered so like
viewership was crazy it was the biggest
Fortnight event at the time I think I
had like 900k viewers because no one
could get in the game I was doing a live
stream for the events was this on
YouTube yeah well I I was the number one
uh for that day like when everyone was
streaming I happen to be the number one
Stream So when the servers went down and
only so many people were in the game
yeah everyone just flooded to YouTube so
all right it was just like
but the point is I I was saying there
was like a delay in the event for some
reason and I was like oh this event gave
me blue balls
it was the most
thing I was watching this with my night
now I have to explain to my
nine-year-old daughter what blue balls
are I'm just like why why do you have to
explain
well you don't no one asked you explain
that
I was probably saying [__] [__] and
stuff before it so like do your due
diligence as a parent to know what your
kids are watching and whether they
should be allowed to watch me that's all
I'm saying yeah the moment you hear that
Australian accent you should be on
higher work yeah yeah yeah it's just
like that doesn't seem like my problem I
gotta ask because like you know when you
have your normal viewers on a live
stream you know you don't really bat an
eye at it because you're so used to
having this kind of audience when it was
getting up to like when you had like 900
000 you're starting to get like a little
little nervous you're like oh God this
is it was just a lot of people it's
definitely weird
but I think because it was a fortnight
event you know I knew they weren't it
wasn't so much about me it was kind of
like oh yeah
just show it off it's just kind of cool
but minimize that box of you in the
corner and shrink it and be like sure I
honestly could I could have been on mute
no one give a [__] I feel like once it
goes past a certain number I just don't
think about it that's true yeah like
it'd be a lot more stressful when you
first started and you get 10 viewers
yeah when you go from like
10K concurrence to 50K just it's like
yeah obviously you appreciate it but
like this you're not actually changing
what you're doing yeah yeah have you
tried to I guess like more well not so
much sensor but be more self-conscious
about you know like swearing and just
being Aussie oh I still but more
strategically like I'll say it when it's
necessary
I was talking to uh Mr Beast about a
watch like a couple years ago and he's
like you don't have to swear to be funny
and I was like because he said he used
to be a little bit more edgy back in the
day yeah yeah yeah
and he obviously cleaned himself up a
lot he's talking to me about it because
I was so stressed and my ad rates were
so bad yeah yeah and he's like look I've
got mine to this point from this point
like here's what you got to do
and he's just like you don't have to
swear to be funny I'm like but so that
goes against every Australian like yeah
yeah she's such a fun word to say yeah
so he's like but yeah so I sort of toned
it back and I was like okay
I'll just be more strategic so if like
the [__] really serves the video yeah it
really serves what I'm saying yeah then
I say it but now like you've got to just
be more careful in general yeah because
I do like scripted videos and I also
noticed like the big dip and like ad
Revenue when whenever like my older
videos had much more swearing in it so
every time like I script a video now if
I use like a swear word I'm like can I
can I replace this word and it still hit
the same yeah the problem is though 90
of the time I'm just like I need the
[__] there man yeah
I [__] need it
yeah I remember we did a Woody's ruin
our ad rates it's fine yeah
we're in Australia we kind of know when
we're in Australia yeah it's fun yeah
yeah the ad rates are going to go down
it was one of like and probably
I guess in a lot of ways when you're
scripting is probably not as much of an
issue but I did find it stressed me out
so much more and made it so much more
like harder to record yeah because I was
constantly thinking about what I was
saying for the first time ever yeah
there was everything else just always
just be even if like I think early on I
probably put on a little bit more of the
I was a bit louder I was a bit more like
talking full-on yeah but still
everything I was saying was kind of just
whatever just yes also I I like I can
never know sometimes what counts as like
a swear word for like the American
audience or like the American
corporations because I remember we
wanted a panel uh I think it was just me
and Joey that did a panel in uh La uh
and it was like a very very big panel
and we had to like sign a contract being
like you cannot swear
on stage you cannot swear and I'm like
ma'am I understand I will be I will only
speak the queen's English for this panel
and within like the first five minutes I
say God damn it or something oh really
and I I didn't know that counted as a
sweat would never think about it yeah
yeah I just said God damn it and then
they muted my mic because they were like
we said no swearing and I was like what
did I say and they were like you took
the you took the lord's name in vain
yeah that is a swear word if it's not a
gosh darn it yeah it's not on here and I
was like I could not believe it I've
recorded with some people that don't
like you saying like oh yeah God damn it
or anything they don't like you saying
God in any way which is fair enough I
guess that I'll respect that yeah yeah
it is such a so foreign to me for that
to be very insulting so yeah so like you
said that like that when the apocalypse
happened you were like affected quite
heavily like at to what degree did it
affect you because it's like I feel
especially you know for someone like an
Australian Creator where it's like so
easy to just say [__] and like yeah all
the other words like how like what
percentage of your channel just got
[__] over
um I mean so every video is demonetized
and it was for like
18 months until I started fortnite it
was actually like now if I look back a
lot of them got greened again but yeah
right how many videos are we talking
like I was I was doing like I was doing
daily I played roughly at that point so
like every video
um and obviously there's people so far
worse off because like I was able to
move back with my parents and stuff and
I was probably still earning like
Grand a month or so yeah I'm sitting
here to move back in with your power
yeah well I lived in Sydney it's just
like I was paying like 600 bucks a week
rent or something like that it's like
so I ended up like having someone else
move in to pay the rent and then I just
went back to my parents oh my God and so
like but it's more of the fact that like
yeah I'll still probably doing like four
or five k a month on revenue or
something but like
it was like but it wasn't adding up for
the news you were getting right and that
might have been Australian dollars too
so that was like I don't know this like
two three k yeah
it's like I had enough to live but it's
like then there's no savings and stuff
and it's like you're right on that edge
of like this is obviously enough to live
that's like especially at that point in
my life this is enough to live yeah I
have a slight dip in views yeah yeah
it's like because it's dangerous yeah
it's like okay then I'm actually got
like so that's like it was more of the
anxiety of being on the edge of that
right um and granted bless my audience
they were very supportive at the time
because I was very transparent about I
was like
and it was just like you know obviously
plenty of creators also still work and
do YouTube at the same time respect that
massively but it's like once you break
out like once I left the job site go it
was just like it's a scary thing it's
like yeah this is not gonna last forever
this could disappear like if I have one
little dip I'm just it's just done yeah
yeah yeah and yeah I know massively
privileged too that like my parents
would still house me you know a lot of
people obviously don't have that either
so my situation was nowhere near as bad
as it could be but yeah it just created
so much unnecessary stress I think like
I was as soon as they started you could
like review the videos yeah that's when
it got back up to like four or five k a
month right right because like some of
them would go back to being green at
some point yeah yeah yeah so like we
write a lot of YouTubers who kind of
just like fell into the occupation like
out of I guess like accidents because
they never I guess they never thought
that this would be a job but it sounds
like you got into this with the
expectations that you're like I want to
make this my job I want this to be my
career like what when did you start to
realize okay I can actually make this a
thing honestly like that like first
three months on the gaming channel I was
like damn shit's easy
I'm actually [__] amazing
um no I mean I have massive imposter
syndrome so like the entire time bro so
everyone yeah every YouTube yeah yeah
yeah I was like this is this is going
away it's like I'm actually making [__]
videos why is anyone watching this it's
all Bots or something but I was like
well I'm not gonna quit where it's
working I don't know
um
bad I don't know always never felt valid
are you ever gonna go back to the
construction routes where you just start
smashing and [__]
um
we should revisit it yeah yeah yeah that
sounds like a long ten year period yeah
yeah yeah
if I can get like a proper team to do
the proper slow-mo like I am the slo-mo
guys like I do know gavinclair well
maybe get him over here buddy yeah feel
me smashing something with an excavator
um I mean yeah it'd be fun I've I have
had something written down for ages to
remake my first videos right that'd be
great free videos I just don't like
leaving the house I don't like touching
across so thank you for coming out but I
just feel like real world production
intimidates me a lot I know how to like
build something out in the gaming space
or even when I did Real World stuff it
was always a vlog like this bless
everyone all the everyone doing the
production here yeah it's stresses me
are you building a studio now was that
sorry aren't you building a studio we
are we are but still it's mostly just
gonna be me sitting at a desk there
they've just got like uh like offices
around it yeah yeah and like I I mean I
might build off like a lot of what
locky's doing and his experience and
even work with the people here yeah
knowing them quite well now I might do
some real world things might see me uh
my favorite ones it's like a slasher so
it's like a big lawnmower that you put
on a Bobcat you can tilt it up you can
throw things into it so imagine throwing
things in a giant lawnmower blade
this podcast is brought to you by cash
app with tools for saving and spending
it's the best place for you to level up
your money and glow up your life and
that's exactly what you need because
guys I do not know how much money I've
spent on gotcha how do I fix that guys
you need cash app in your life but what
does cash app do Connor well gone you
can keep track of your own coin because
you'll see that balance update
immediately when you waste all that
money on gacha so you always know when a
payment went through all it takes to pay
someone is their phone number email or
cash tag you can even scan their QR code
straight from the app so you can pay me
back now yeah exactly you can pay me
back right you'll pay me back oh me yeah
you'll pay me oh yeah you owe me some
money as well thanks for cash out and
not only that you can save on everyday
spending as well get exclusive discounts
with the cash app pay and cash cards and
you know what cash app lets you Bank the
way that you want thank God Gamers I've
recently been playing RPGs and I would
never go against the final boss under
leveled I grind that [__] out so why
would I go into the world not having
grind my financials so like the gamer
over there if you want to level up in
your life you got to level up on your
money so download cash app in the app
store Google Play Store in the link link
down in the description below with no
hidden fees and a free to order debit
card it feels like a cheat code for your
finances back to the episode so
obviously you started doing fortnite and
that's where things kind of went great
that was the big yes so how did you go
from I assume when you started fortnite
it was already out obviously and it kind
of already had its own scene how did you
kind of see it and be like I think I can
do this differently and then how did
that translate to you becoming the
number one yeah so I mean I think when
it came out I had a million Subs so I
definitely wasn't like stuff yeah I was
doing like 150k yeah like a video or
something
um I started when it first came out so
before anyone was really making videos
on it I was like I was there I wasn't
the first but I was like I was within
the first week or two of them I was sort
of at least playing it but then I was
having big issues with my eyes which I
still do to this day but um so I like I
stopped kind of gaming for a little bit
I don't know um so I left it for like
three or four months and then I started
seeing everyone going skits on it I'm
like yeah
[__] them I wanna like what the hell
this is [__]
um on the pie they're getting like six
mil views of video daily on this like
this game's crazy and like I loved
playing it but it was just like
genuinely I couldn't look at computer
screens I was in heaps of pain uh oh
sure so I just said [__] it [__] my pain
I'm just gonna do it it's like burning
like all right guys
I sum it up by calling it like I ligma
but I have like three like conditions
which is
but basically it means my eyes are
always red uh I'm in massive amounts of
pain when I look at a computer screen
and uh there's no moisture in Mars
um so it was just I picked the worst
profession in the world too yeah yeah
right look at the [__] screen but I
was like damn it was do or die I'm like
that's that's the most Aussie solution
I've ever heard in my life just like
[__] it mate yeah generally I was like
look how big this is I genuinely love
playing the game I love when I can make
videos on it I just want to do it I'm
just going to have to toughen the [__]
up and do it
I don't know I don't know any other
person would have been like maybe I
should just do other content yeah yeah
yeah oh I try to do like uh Vlogs for a
little bit again
um I just struggled so much with like
organizing [__] to do my coastal town
like what the hell am I going to do
every day yeah like it was like Logan
Paul was popping off and I'm like yeah
how do they come up with [__] to do
everything yeah producers
producers yeah doing that on Bloody
Central Coast saying yeah given it's a
lot harder when you're not near much
yeah so I mean I think it was kind of
similar to the sports videos where
everyone was like people were definitely
doing challenges they were doing meme
things they were having fun
but I was just so [__] at the game and I
still am but I just think I probably had
a slightly different
way of seeing things like it goes back
to that like even if I other people
doing challenges I just didn't a little
differently yeah yeah it's like slightly
differently I had done so many different
games of some stuff you did oh God
so the first one that was like the big
viral one was the first ever Fortnight
event I tried to stop it
I know it sounds simple now because so
many people other people did it yeah
like later on yeah
but not everyone else went they just
watched the first Fortnight event right
one of my bless I think was toasted had
the idea well sitting in Discord it's
like what if we stop it I was like that
sounds like a [__] mad idea
we practice it so we tried we didn't
succeed what was the strategy uh so we
just built a box around the rocket ship
I don't know if you ever played fortnite
or saw that event or whatever it was but
it was like a massive that was Peak
fortnite that was like ninja playing
with Drake era
um it was a rocket ship just going in
the sky so we're like let's build around
wait wait so how did this event work
like there's Rockets oh so just in the
game at random one point it was like
they added this rocket ship to the game
and then like a few weeks later
it just took off right and it was like
it was like a countdown it was like the
first ever like worldwide in-game event
that everyone was participating in the
same so everyone shared the same space
or like so everyone if you loaded into a
game was seeing the thing the exact same
time but everyone was in different games
oh but it was just happening at the same
so you do different things where you'd
like have the time exactly when you
joined the lobby some people like the
game's ending as it was happening some
people got eliminated had to spectate it
happening
um but yeah we loaded up like practicing
we practiced a couple times watch Bill
like how quickly we could build it
um and then we built around it and it
just took off straight through it but it
was bang a thumbnail and people just
love the energy of like sitting there
just doing some dumb [__] like everyone
else just wanted to watch it yeah the
only one that did anything different for
that event which is so that's kind of
like your content brand just taking a
game and just being like let's just do
some [__] dumb [__] we've got it when
you're not good at him you gotta like
you know do weird [__]
um like I my favorite fortnite videos
the one where I won without moving
um and that's just the same energy it's
like everyone tries to get like 30 bombs
get 30 kills a month
but it's because I stream snapped my
friend who was in the same office
without him knowing and he was like a
psychopath at the game
um and I still got like one in a million
all the perfect circles all that right
but I was sitting in a tree I landed
straight in the tree sat there all game
um just got all the perfect circles like
one in the million he just deleted the
whole Lobby had no idea I was in the
game yeah looking for the last player
he's like where is this dude it's me I'm
in the tree so then I ran into his
office kicked him out of the game and I
got the victory right now so that was
like yeah I tried for a week to get it
um like just without stream sniping yeah
but I was like [__] I want to finish
this video I have to figure out how can
you actually do this and think outside
the box all right and actually I'd spent
like three months prior to that trying
to win completely AFK I had someone
literally I paid someone to just film
the screen as they just load into the
game and just don't touch anything just
to see if you can win completely AFK so
it was kind of like an evolving idea it
wasn't possible like it technically yes
at any point like was there anything
we've got a couple top threes and stuff
AFK but the circles would never go to
where the AFK players would drop right
right so it's just you'd have to be so
obscenely lucky the odds just weren't in
your favor we've played like 2 000 games
or something oh my God at one point
we're running like three accounts
but yeah no it was just like
you know I'm [__] so I can't do what
some of these other people are doing I
don't know what's organic to me that
makes sense yeah I mean you're using
that to your strength right and I feel
that's like something that it seems like
something that anyone can do but just
like it's it's it's the difference
between being like Oh yeah I could do
some dumb stuff because I don't have the
skills to actually like play the game
normally and then there's a difference
of actually committing to doing it right
and I think that's like the massive
gonna sit there for a week filming
something you know that's another thing
everyone else not everyone else like
that's like a very general statement but
maybe like some of the people that I
knew where I was watching or something
like everyone was so obsessed with like
the daily fortnite upload yeah and I I
was forbid I would try and stick to it
but I was definitely like if this video
needs an extra couple days I'm gonna
give it to it yeah for sure yeah
um well I've heard uh that a meme now is
uh a meme that's crept up is uh your
upload schedule oh yeah no it's dog [__]
yeah what's uh is that to do with your
eye
in some ways because I added
like I got help on like a couple videos
maybe like 10 or 15 right videos
throughout the years but otherwise I
edited every single video I ever
uploaded what wait do you still do that
uh if it's on my main Channel mostly
like I get some it was like nowadays if
it's on the main Channel someone will
like
do one of the run-throughs I'll add some
like extra things here but I'm still
doing the rough cut organizing I'm still
doing the Final Cuts and sometimes I'm
still doing the whole thing well that's
definitely not helping your Island um no
right so like God I think you're you're
this big and you still like edit your
own videos yeah I know like I'm still
I'm trying I'm like I'm trying people
I'm trying to get out of this yeah it is
like a mental ill I don't know it's a
bad thing you should never do it it's
amazingly important early on to
definitely do everything yourself oh
yeah yeah you need to learn the skills
you need to know how to edit so when
you're talking to someone who edits
you're just like an idiot yeah yeah you
know what they're going through to make
something happen so you're not giving
unreasonable demands or something like
that I think it's very important is it
just like the is it the anxiety of
handing off something that you made to
someone else or sometimes because I
think that's like a big issue with like
that was an issue with me when I first
got my editor where it's like I was
editing my own stuff for the first like
four or five years of my career and then
when I finally got to that point where
I'm like [__] I don't have the time to
like make these
yeah and also like I'm just not very
good at anything in general so it's like
and I don't have the time to improve on
it so I always had that anxiety of like
well what if I give it to someone and
it's not exactly to the vision that I
wanted to or like how do I keep I don't
want to be that annoying dude to just
like constantly tell my editor like fix
this fix this fix this when I could just
do it myself right like did you have
that anxiety yeah I feel like I
definitely struggle because I just
like no matter what and like I don't
want to say everyone sucks not everyone
sucks but definitely people have
different styles they have different
approaches yeah and I think I suck at
the fact that I am not very good at like
giving notes and stuff I'm like that
kind of person like oh [__] I was doing
myself like they'll send me back like a
test anyway ah [__] I'll just finish it
yeah I was like because I'm like oh I
don't want to sit here I get frustrated
right
um like I said it's me being broken in
the brain I'm a very cooked individual
did all my own thumbnails did all that
that's just I thumbnails like another
sound because thumbnails I would argue
is more important than the editing of
the video sometimes yeah yeah sometimes
because I mean yeah I I still have not
found someone that can edit thumbnails
exactly the way I want to uh yeah but
like in terms of doing your own editing
I'm still involved in my own kind of
like editing when it comes to my own
videos but in terms of like rough cut
that's that's a lot of work I I just do
like the finishing touches man yeah
especially for someone like you who's
like filming for like weeks yeah that's
why I don't don't give it to them
because I know exactly from that like
week of recording what I want in it
right so like what are they going to go
through like 25 hours of raw footage or
am I just going to go okay well 14 hours
that was dog [__] I know you can start
stop recording but I hate doing that
right I'd rather do like big chunks and
I go okay I know this part I want in and
I'll just do I'll do that right yeah we
uh we filmed we filmed a video where we
kind of like just drove from like the
most southern point of Japan to like the
most northern point in Japan and we had
like how many hours of footage do we
have for that one well it was it was a
10-day road trip and there was seven
cameras on it yeah
yeah and we did not give our editor any
notes
we just dumped away and I'll even go
through that though so sorry
I don't see that's where I'm like I
struggle I'm not like the best like when
it comes to like managing people
production processes or whatever yeah
yeah I'd have zero goddamn clue yeah how
many people are you working with now how
big is your team oh I think there's
technically five of us five but that's
mostly just like I you know
especially like oh I'm making a video on
Roblox like help me find like help me
test these Roblox games like more of
like
even if I come up with the initial idea
a lot of time it's helping me find the
stuff I need to make it around sometimes
a lot of videos just to have like that
annoying anyone could do this it just
takes 10 hours or five hours to do the
basic thing you're like I don't have
time
it's also good just bounce off people
get different perspectives especially
like yeah yeah I do Tick Tock videos or
something I'm not just pulling up a
YouTube compilation of tick tocks or
scrolling my own tick tocks it's like
I said that I sent those boys and I said
you've got a week find me the best hour
of tech talks and I'll watch the hour
and then we'll cut it down to 10 minutes
right that's like the selection process
for for that like that will literally
sit there for a week and grind out and
find like I think I said one time in the
start of one of them like I locked them
in a room and force them to watch Tick
Tock Twitter and I pretty much did
except they're in their own offices yeah
like
I just yeah I mean that's Parts like
because I don't want to watch tick tocks
first yeah yeah so that part I I'm you
know I find it easy to get help because
you know it's it's
yeah it's like it's it's not the most
complicated thing but it's still like
they need to be funny they don't need to
understand what humor is yeah you still
do need to find the right people yeah
but well that part's been all right yeah
I mean for a for a YouTuber your size
five people is actually like a really
[__] small team yeah from from like
people we've talked to at least I mean
Mr Beast as a 5 000 people yeah it's
like a village or something he's
disgusting yes
I went yeah no in like a like
disgustingly good kind of way you know
what I mean yeah you've done a lot of
videos with them yeah I visited Preston
as well I don't know if you know Preston
but he's got like a team of like
40 or 50 or something now people
everywhere what's that YouTube handle uh
Preston YT I think he did a lot of like
Minecraft stuff and like uh gaming stuff
right
what the [__] are they doing I don't
yeah I mean they they pump out they're
crushing so like they're doing something
yeah
actually like it's uh the first time I
heard about you actually because uh I
don't normally like play fortnite so I'm
not really like in that scene uh yeah I
mean I don't play it as much as that
uh but yeah it was was actually I was
actually from a Mr Beast video it was
the private uh the private jet video
that uh uh yeah the hand on the private
jet yeah okay so awful experience
exposing Mr Beast right now everything
he fakes it all fakes all these videos
he he like hit us with bats every now
and then wouldn't let us go to the
bathroom yeah yeah so I I think the
concept of the video was like lost to
take the hand off the jet yeah did you
I was there for 20 hours thank you very
much I left two hours before the end so
what's it like filming on a Mr Beast
video that in turns where I
I've known him for a few years right
um but
had never been I guess like I
technically was in a video but I've
never been in a video before
and I think it made me appreciate him a
lot more because I've been in videos
with some people who
they'll like blow the edges a little bit
they're like force things to happen if
it needs to happen for the video right
he is when it comes to filming the most
authentic individual because like
he wants it to happen like for real like
there's no like there was a whole thing
where he had booked out like other
airports with like other activities that
were supposed to fly to in the Jet right
but because enough people didn't get
eliminated in time for us to get like
the clearance to go fly we needed to get
down to like six people seven people or
something
um and we didn't like people didn't drop
off fast enough we just had to scrap all
that
oh my God like that he just like
invested in all this but he never I
respected a lot because he never forced
people to get eliminated yeah he made it
difficult but he was never like one of
you guys got to go like he never games
it he was like if you can withstand this
punishment we'll sit here like we're not
he didn't like rig it so that we would
have to go here or you know we'd have to
get to this number by this time so the
video is done by this time because we've
got to be done he made sure he like
booked out everything for as long as he
needed to like with tons of room
um he made sure like there's no bathroom
breaks like you're going with your hand
on the plane all right
um we're eating with that hand on the
plane oh yeah he put like his little
tent around us oh yeah yeah yeah you had
to smell the urine of the people next to
you oh my god disgust did anyone need to
[__] no one likely needed oh god um I
guess luckily enough there was no women
on the shoot in Africa because like I
would feel so bad for them that would be
like a cancel Mr Beast moment that would
be mistreating him
um but yeah he's just so authentic and
real when it comes to that and that's
why he has so many people and like so
many stuff and like he has all these
contingency plans for every sort of
outcome because he wants it to be
authentic yeah and I was like he didn't
even blur any lines he was like
this your hand is on the jet if you keep
your hand on the jet you win the jet
that's it right there's no [__] was
it torturous
awful awful and because everyone else
was a psychopath like we're all just
standing there and you just had to keep
you can't sit down anymore you can't
rescue any surface that was like resting
your hands slightly can't do it you have
to be held up like on top of the gym
and then he taped us together to another
competitor and that's what did me and I
was I just couldn't handle the tape
anymore I had a bloke next to me he was
like leaning on me I was landing on him
and then yeah everyone else had their
tape removed because certain people got
eliminated so they'll just had no tape
anymore and I was like just flip the
coin see if I can get rid of the tape
yeah how much did he tell you prior to
like shooting because it was like how
did he picture just like hey I'm doing
this video with a problem doing this
video hands going on a jet do you want
to be in it it's not very complicated
although we went to go
now that was we went to go film it and
then I think it got
canceled at the move the date right so
we've got we got all the shooting
location turn around that was fun but
that's because like everything wasn't
ready you didn't want it to be yeah yeah
yeah [__] so then we have to film it
the day after the Cyberman charity match
so everyone was like exhausted I didn't
sleep really before at all
um there's a lot of eye ligma in that
video I was looking very fried I do not
do drugs it is purely from a medical
condition
um so yeah I mean he picked the worst
day that's why like half the sidemen
weren't in it because yeah if I can't be
asked that was that supposed to be more
originally ah yeah no I think it was
meant to be like I don't know if I'm
leaking [__] but nothing matters I don't
think but
uh yeah no I think originally it was
meant to be like all the sidemen yeah
yeah just except I think Vic was the
only one were you in the side man
charity match yes I was but you're easy
to miss me because
[__] did nothing
I'm not an athletic individual so if you
guys don't know the channel
charity matches just basically they just
do football game rent out a stadium it's
actually pretty [__] cool yeah one of
the best moments it's very British and
they play football walking on a pitch in
front of like it was like 30 000 people
or something unreal it's insane it's
such a cool concert I love sport but I'm
obviously not athletic so I got to like
role play for like a day which position
did you play ah kind of
I think I was midfield for most of it
played uh yeah I think I was left back
at one point against speed oh my God he
was doing some weird things saying some
weird [__]
nice guy though actually really nice
surprise me you're any good at footy no
no I was just I run like a penguin right
I was just like running like such a
goofy dumbass like the whole time
watching the Clips back later I'm like I
did not need to see that you know have
you ever considered how you run you've
probably never thought about it have you
you well no you because you'd never
[__] see it you just don't think
about it until you see it especially
when you're in past quality yeah you see
broadcast quality of you trying to
Sprint after a football
[__] it it's eye-opening
shocked so you never run again I don't
think I'm running again yeah just
wearing it off I go for jogs and stuff
and I'm like thinking everyone walking
past me seen they're seeing that they're
seeing me running like a penguin no I'm
penguin I've got a [__] in my pants I'm
trying to squeeze my cheeks boy as a kid
though I I play baseball
that's why everyone says sucked at
baseball oh gosh I didn't I don't have
my brother's genetics
damn did you only play baseball or like
any other sports as well
um mostly baseball I did a little like
School Sport and stuff yeah because
what's nice in a rugby what's normally
in Australia for like the curriculum
because in like in in in England
obviously you have like 30 uh cricket as
well yes as well I think for us it's
like Cricket like footy like rugby yeah
that's pretty much it right pretty much
it that's all I like all I did for PE
was like yeah pretty much just Cricket
yeah yeah not not keeping your hand on
the the jet no no nothing prepared me
for them why didn't the school prepare
me for the real [__] man I think if I if
I just slept the night before
or if I just could if I won that coin
flip to get the tape off I reckon I won
this episode is sponsored by grammarly
boys as a certified CEO I have to write
a lot of emails to clients right but
sometimes I just can't be bothered to
come up and formulate all of these
different responses in a professional
manner
words are hard thankfully grammarly is
there to help me Gremlin is an AI power
tool that's been in the space for 10
years now it assists with all aspects of
writing including brainstorming and
revising if you ever need a little bit
of help just click that green button and
there you go you've got to write in your
prompt of the help that you need it's
that easy yeah Grandma's got your bag
yeah plus sometimes I need to get
through all of those piles of emails so
much quicker luckily grammarly can help
me summarize my emails and provide
suggestions on how to reply in mere
seconds and boys I'll be honest
sometimes I'm a little dumb as you know
I need somebody to help me write English
good and grammarly got my back and best
of all guys grammarly is free to try out
guys free sign up for an account at
grammarly.com trashtaste 06 if you want
to get access to extra features and get
20 off grammarly premium
damn that's a deal go down the link in
the description below and thank you to
grammarly for sponsoring today's episode
this episode is sponsored by box who
what should delivers the experience of
tasting authentic Japanese snacks
candies and tea sauce directly from
Century old small family businesses
right to your door their mission is to
empower Japan's traditional snack makers
by sharing their authentic food and
stories with the world God what do you
got this that's a new box suit for this
it is the new box suit Joey look at all
these delicious snacks guys look at all
well packed the moment you opened it all
fell out this month is of course the
fireworks festival box because right now
there's a lot of summer festivals
happening in Japan so why not experience
a little bit of that summer culture
right in the comfort of your own home
the first box you'll receive is called
these Seasons of Japan kind of like the
greatest hits and following that gone
every month boxu has a different theme
so get your hands on this theme while
you still can oh this is a little snack
that I always get at the corn minis but
I've never seen it in a small version
like this this is which is like a lemon
candy type of thing got that sourness
nice it's so refreshing they're gone is
trying one of the sour gummies with
condensed milk how is it gone that's
really good
yeah not to mention every single boxer
box comes with its own tea pairings as
well so today well this month rather we
have the asikaracha foot patent tea oh
wow I've never heard of it before but
I'm sure it matches perfectly with every
single snack in this box so to get 15
off your first box through snack box now
support our channel uh use our code
trash taste at boxy.com that's
b-o-k-k-s-u.com that is
b-o-k-k-s-u.com with code trash taste
for 15 off your first purchase I'm gonna
finish this episode bye one thing that
uh you did with fortnite which I found
really interesting was that you have a
skin informed yes how the how did all
that go about like was a conversation
they approached you like we don't want
to put yeah no I think they um they
contacted every the first five all
together
I just said hey
we like you you want to be in the game
and you're not going to say no so you
say Obviously yes
um and then you sort of just begin uh I
think for me it was like almost two
years yeah right on that first phone
call I think was August 2019.
um for a long time I didn't actually it
felt I didn't want to skin because which
sounds dumb but it's because I already
had a character uh the gingerbread man
oh right the merry Marauder that was
already so uh integral to my brand and
identity that I felt by just releasing a
skin for the sake of releasing skin it's
cool as it would have been it would feel
disingenuous because it would just be
like backstabbing the gingerbread man
well in some ways but kind of just like
I'm just forcing this out for the sake
of it I don't know like I already was so
attached to this thing yeah yeah but
then
um my girlfriend had the idea of making
it the old me like the young me before
who had the dream of like my fortnite
Skins are trading right it was what I
did beforehand yeah so it was just kind
of instead of trying to be some like
superhero looking thing yeah some crazy
easy outfit which they all look really
cool
um it was just more of like honoring the
kid that always dreamed of being where I
am now which is awesome
but that's why I was okay
yeah let's go a story behind it that's
my one one of my two tattoos is just my
Fortnight
what's your other tattoo uh [__] this I
I don't regret it but it's definitely a
lot it sounds like a lot oh no what is
it
okay so when I I was a [__] broken
record I could not stop saying yeet like
you would have been I don't know I'm
assuming like the cold ones one comes
out before this yeah yeah but like Chad
all he does is say double it and give it
to the next one that's all he says he
always says to me so Mike same thing
broken record I couldn't stop saying you
if it was already a dead meme so I made
it my meme the fact that was a dead meme
I just couldn't stop saying it yeah so
and then I was like it's a fun word to
say yeah but I was planning on getting
tattoos all up this arm so it wasn't
gonna be quiet
yeah well I remember Joey went through a
phrase where he just would continually
dab even when the dabbing me oh yeah I
was getting that [__] away yeah nothing
wrong with a good dab hit a bottle flip
I think one year it was like 2016 2017
way off to like the dab had already died
I was just like I'm gonna challenge
myself to see that if every photo I take
and I upload onto the internet is of me
dabbing oh God yeah and I did it for the
entire year if you look up any photo
from like 2016 2017 it's me Dad there
isn't a single normal photo I mean
that's holding a fidget spinner or
something yeah yeah yeah I
actually I hit a fidget spinner with a
sledgehammer once and it slammed in my
ankle and like like fractured my ankle
that's the one video I made with the
fidget spinner
yeah no it was like a metal one I was
like oh I reckon I could break this
Sledgehammer so I hit it and just
slammed in Miami versus ten thousand
dollar fidget spinner it probably was
some cringe ass title
so you got the skin made and then it
came out and what was the reaction like
it was funny because like a lot of
people love the message behind it but
everyone who was an Australian had no
[__] clue what it was what was that I
didn't know what a train they don't want
to trade it because it like what was the
skin name what was it just called it's
just called laser okay I'm pretty sure I
think it's just laser baby yeah
um but what was the message behind it
well it was just pretty much just like
well his old self yeah it was my old
self because I I did a video and like I
did the lowest production value video
out of anyone who announced their skin
it was funny I did the thumbnail like 30
minutes before it went up I was sitting
in Disco with lucky like this looks
alright isn't it it's only like one of
the biggest moments of your life yeah
he's throwing this [__] together last
minute I'm like Abby right
um yeah so I kind of did a video on a
job site that uh my dad's working on
actually so it's kind of like it was a
throwback I went there I just talked
about skin why I picked what I did
um so a lot of people really like that
but they're just like
like everyone else is all these glowy
characters yeah yeah hey look the skin
did well so I'm like people still you
know supported this that's we love that
but um yeah yeah everyone really
responded well to to the message behind
it definitely and also another big thing
for fortnite creators that I don't think
I've seen any other game do is the
tattoo you have it's that in Roblox yeah
Roblox has a star code which is also you
can use code laser oh my God but that
doesn't do as well because like
kids have to steal their parents credit
cards for that yeah you should not do
unless you are using codes
explain what the credit code is people
who might not know what it was one of
the most amazing brilliant things and I
will forever be grateful to epic games
for it because it basically allowed it
so you had another way to support people
making content so they made it so that
if when you're buying skins uh you could
enter a code and the person whose code
would get five percent of the purchase
right so it just gave us a lot there
were so many people who had like just
different forms of content map Builders
uh Instagram Pages things that didn't
necessarily generate lots of AD revenue
or something like that yeah yeah
for me early on when I was getting
really bad ad rates with fortnite I was
still making decent money because the
views were so crazy but like it was
massive for me like yeah it was such a
massive thing for me
um it gave so much more security where
like you know ads were inconsistent
um right and that's just for me about
like percent of her skins especially
beginning to 10 million view video
that's yeah it was it was good it was
good and I think it just made it like so
it was viable for so many more creators
to actually make content full-time or
yeah you know be around the game full
time and obviously it was a brilliant
decision for them because of bred so
much creative loyalty yeah yeah and then
yeah you see a lot of people do it now
um yeah yeah yeah well starting to at
least I think they're still doing it now
yeah no they still do it now although
the codes do expire every 14 days which
was brilliant from them because even I
forget to put my own code in when I buy
skins oh so you have to you have to
re-enter it every 14 days oh which is
fine because I guess the idea is they
want people to do different codes but I
thought you would have had to have done
it for every purchase anyway
the thing is is like a lot of people on
fortnite are on console and they'll they
want to type right so when I change my
code was originally laser beam and then
I changed it to laser and like usage of
my code went up like 50 60 just because
people are short and lazy yeah and I get
it I'm with them I'm with them that's
crazy that it's that big of a difference
over I just I can't remember the exact
number like but it was definitely like
significant increase oh wow [__] yeah we
talked to Lachlan a bit about the I
guess the economy of Roblox because I I
I know basically nothing the stock
exchange the stock exchange is [__]
mad yeah
and tell like yeah they would like
people would I guess like make a [__]
Sweatshop or something except the kids
would like me maps
uh well I guess like what is that about
like I I did not get like the full
picture can you can you explain to me
what the economy of Roblox is Roblox is
yeah yeah
it's an interesting thing because I only
really make videos taking the piss out
of the game
like I'll I will just say I'll spend
like 10 grand and pay to win and just
like I almost say bully kids because
they can always leave the game so
they're kind of they're choosing they're
choosing they're choosing to get
destroyed oh yeah but yeah like all
these Roblox games not all of them but a
lot of them are pay to win right
um how so well okay so like I mean
one of my favorite ones is like there's
this game we can just like slap it's
like slap battles yeah you meant to
slowly grind the most people you slap
the more points you get you get a better
hand to slap people with it's like a
plane with Lego it's funny yeah but
there you can just go in and spend like
20 bucks and buy like a god hand and
you're unkillable and everyone who joins
lobbies slap the [__] out of him and he
just you just knock them off the mat and
they can't do anything about it and it's
the funniest thing I'm like this is ten
dollars this is cheaper than a movie and
I'm sitting here have a time my life
so I guess like a lot of kids like just
love buying that [__] there's also you
can buy items it's like there's
thousands of games all right um which is
like anyone can make a game anyone can
upload any game and then you can
monetize it however you want right right
um and I think you get 30 so if someone
spends 100 on your game you get 30 right
um and yeah there's just a nasty cut
from them I feel like they provide the
service the game engine I've talked to
developers about it because I thought
the same thing but the developer seemed
some of them at least seem quite happy
okay with it but you can create like
Cosmetics you can have so a lot of them
are like pet simulators and stuff where
you buy you buy and trade pets like it's
[__] Pokemon except they all just
look like squares and like bless those
guys they help me make a video so like
the game's fun and it's just addicting
and it's just like kids just love
collecting these pets and upgrading
their pets and having more powerful pets
and you know they spend money to get
those pets and you come along you're
like how could I best ruin this kid's
day oh absolutely so my big thing is
like I just like to spend a bunch of
money to get on high scores right so
like they'll be like these kids at a
grinder for months like you see their
play time 15 minutes 300 number one okay
and I'm like job's done it's a good
lesson to teach kids it's my most
popular video on my channel is the first
episode of that this is like a great
video idea yeah it was it was mad but so
yeah like basically just sell the
Cosmetics whereas for fortnite fortnite
sell the skins in Roblox you just like
people make their skins right right you
buy it off a Marketplace so even your
character that goes from game to game
someone's just made that skin so that's
why you get all the meme ones like
people just run around SpongeBob or like
you know any any character you can think
of any meme at any time right
um and that's just how and they just
take the cut off that it's all pretty
much all ugc like user generated content
Roblox is worth over a I think well over
a billion dollars yeah sounds crazy that
it's worth I think it's it's the most
valuable game it's the most played game
I'm pretty sure it hits uh on update
nights for it which I don't know what
they are
um but it gets up to 10 million
concurrent players yeah it's it's not
like not like daily active like
concurrent yeah there is more people
probably playing right one of the
there's a game called blocks fruits
which has at any given time 300 000 to
600 000 concurrent players playing a
Roblox game oh my God about being an
anime character I'm pretty I think it
might be based off like one piece but
like a rip-off block fruits yeah but it
has more players concurrently than all
the fortnite game modes
epic games his biggest game has less
concurrent players than [__] blocks
fruit and I'm like that's a compliment
to [__] boxers it's a great game but
like what the [__]
it works in a browser yeah it's on a
phone yeah man yeah that's like two big
things I'll just make it like easy you
know it's so Lego pieces with anime
swords
and there's more players in all of
because fortnite recently just showed it
so like they'll show their concurrent
players because they're trying to do a
similar thing yeah were they like
there's all these fortnite Maps they
want to do a lot of ugc generated stuff
but and so now they show you how many
people are in Battle Royale right now
yeah
I'm getting from this I gotta play
blocks fruits
probably every 10 year old in the world
is playing blockages
they are making tens of millions of
dollars a year how do they get around
copyright if it's like user generated
um it's a golden question yeah yeah I
mean if there's this much money and this
model
I feel like the big boys like say blocks
first just everything's a different name
everything looks slightly different but
maybe it's got a similar energy but for
people making like meme skins I I just
don't think they care like they just
like ban them if it's like bad or
something right right I don't know but
you'll see people running around with
some funny ass characters in Roblox yeah
because because I I guess it's like it
sounds like a similar thing to like say
VR chat or something where all like the
avatars yeah it's definitely the
generator is [__] great yeah but
except I don't think I think right now
it's mostly user generated and I don't
know if they're making a profit or
anything like that well there isn't 600
000 people in VR chat yeah that's that's
the thing right that's the thing VR
channels have blocked through man that's
crazy I don't know but it's I think
Roblox is also like the biggest game on
YouTube right now like Far and Away
right views right we just never
necessarily see it but it's yeah I guess
because it's if you're our age you
definitely don't yeah no it's it's not
for me from like a Content watching
thing necessarily yeah yeah yeah
guys playing it
so I recommend everyone who has you know
like a little bit just go bullies you
you are teaching these kids a valuable
capitalism
would always sell them with a fatter
wallet 100
there's one thing I want to ask you
about this is my one of my favorite
fortnite controversies oh really yeah uh
what was it's not really about fortnite
but there was uh I mean you probably
even probably know all about this it was
just I know you guys might not know
about this it was this kid uh who was in
the FaZe Clan called Java oh I don't
know about that so what he did was he
had the you know because content was
running a little dry he had the big
brain idea of what if I made a video
where I downloaded an Aimbot and showed
off an Aimbot in like normal like oh
yeah
it was like a it was like a cultural
moment it wasn't just a fortnight it was
huge you know cheating was rampant but
he went into like a normal non-ranked
game I think and just showed off what it
was like and what these tutors were
using right yeah and then he got a
lifetime ban from permanent man uh
yeah I mean think about that I just want
to hear your take on it [__] [__] for
hacking like it's an obvious thing just
don't you don't mess with that at all
but like you said he's young he was
young sorry it's it's such a it was such
a weird case she was like obviously
you're a [__] idiot but yeah I think
it's like a double standard thing right
it was usually because if they made the
exception for him because he's young and
he is popular
he was good at the game he was hacking
to show a point or make a funny video
whatever
but it's like where do you draw the line
then on like other people's band appeals
and stuff like that it was a tough spot
for epic to be in I would have unbanned
him but
you know they could have also banned him
and had a time limit on it which was
also another option but I think it's
just like the usual thing is a hardware
IP ban every person but I would say the
one argument I have against that is
usually because most people who are
banned do not have their identity
attached to it yeah they do uh they are
able to get around yeah yeah but he was
like it's not just like he couldn't make
fortnite videos anymore he would get
sued yeah even if he like made the video
and like you know didn't show the
character name or made a new account
every time I made a video he would get
sued like so he had absolutely no choice
I think I think yeah he probably should
have been unbanned but how did a bit of
a [__] did they get resolved or no they
just moved games and you know credit to
him he's he's found ways to Pivot
throughout the years but it's just a
shame because he
he was good he was popping off he was
going crazy yeah huge news when it
happened I remember it was and then
everyone had an opinion because it was
as everyone does on Twitter it's a good
story
whether they should or should in this
I've got thoughts on this yeah I mean
like I I think I saw this on a clip like
somewhere on some person like explaining
it and I mean it seemed like he was very
sorry about it but I guess okay
she was very very sorry about it but I
don't know it was a [__] dumb thing
to do yeah it's kind of like I guess in
in my field like I would it would be
like hey there's this website that you
can do to watch anime like illegally by
the way I'm just showing it off not
because I promote it but here let me
just show it off yeah let me just show
it off the watches are yeah yeah let me
just show it off to all my viewer base
yeah yeah yeah
you know what I mean like that's like no
difference it's just like putting a
mountain of cocaine on the table being
like you see this this is bad
I mean well you're just racking it up
yeah it's like don't this is better I'm
going to show you how bad it is yeah I'm
going to show you the effects of this
and how bad it is right now drugs are
bad
drugs is terrible like officer your
honor I was just trying to show you the
kids yeah like the reason like 50 of why
I was glad I got into youtubing after
the age of 18. so yeah yeah yeah well I
think it's like an interesting thought
and I think of this with a lot of
YouTube controversy where people do
something dumb it's like there is a
feedback loop that happens on YouTube
yep and like say I use Logan Paul's
example they're not comparable
situations but I would say large amounts
of the time you're making content you
get a positive response you go a little
bit more extreme with that content you
do something more outlandish you go a
little bit more wild with it yeah more
of a positive response the more extreme
the video the more extreme emotions
you're engaging more extreme the views
response I'd say with like Logan and his
Forest thing obviously horrible thing to
do but up until that every time he did
something crazy getting constantly like
positive feedback everyone on Twitter
even honestly in general I would say at
the time he was in YouTube Rewind he was
the face of YouTube at the time he was
getting four 500 million views a month
I'm not saying whether he was doing the
right thing all the time I'm there was a
good chunk of people who on the internet
who were not a fan though even before
that I think that was like the yes this
he finally yeah it was like a full
opposite ends of the spectrum but I'd
say even the bubble he was in I was
saying like well he could be a bad
person anyway I'm just saying that like
for that thing he was con constantly
going crazy or getting more good results
from it yeah I don't think he started
out saying this is a great idea this is
where I want to end up you know and
obviously it's very different to the
Java situation but I would say in
fortnite at the time like oh yeah people
who were doing videos of like catching a
hacker or something like that you're
getting all these positive responses
that makes it so you don't fully
consider all the potential outcomes for
what you're actually creating especially
like it's it's always interesting to see
when a video gets posted or when you
know your own kind of content and your
own kind of character gets judged to an
audience that's outside of your
established audience as well yeah
because you sometimes you don't
sometimes you get kind of a reality
check uh especially you know with
someone like Logan Paul or someone on
that size where you you get the feedback
that you don't normally expect yeah you
know and you you get they can be healthy
obviously like yeah yeah yeah there was
also another video that came out not too
long ago that was kind of similar uh but
I guess very different in delivery and
purpose uh there was a guy who did a
video about off and shooting in tarkov
and he in the video he downloaded an
Aimbot and he was trying to find other
people who were also using a name Bob
and it was really kind of compelling
because there was those moments where
the two Aimbot dudes could see each
other through walls and stuff they were
like noticing each other and giving each
other and they'd be like don't shoot me
I'm also involved go and shoot someone
else we're friends yeah yeah and he was
kind of like documenting it was a really
good video and it kind of threw that
Community into like after all because
they were like what the [__] yeah I
don't let's see like I think there's
been so many videos I've scrapped
because I'm like oh epic might not like
this or this Game Dev might not like I
guess that's also a way where the
Creator code or maybe the skin has a
little bit of power I would say I would
say for sure
um but I I think this just you know how
far can I push it before I get like in
trouble of Epic or something we did this
video where we played old versions of
fortnite that people sort of like
re-uploaded and remade and you're like
we worked out after a while you're fine
to do it long as you don't do the
multiplayer one or you don't use skins
because they don't want it to be like
people can place other fortnite when
you're not buying skins
um so it ended up being fine but it was
like there's a line here and we're here
have you ever been contacted or been
told like epic games told me told me to
take videos down here oh yeah I was
doing like a glitch or some [__] and
they'd be like yeah
and I was like look I love you whatever
you want fair enough because like it was
actually something they just couldn't
fix for a while yeah yeah yeah yeah and
it was like game breaking
uh so it was I think at the time you
could fly a helicopter or something well
above the hype barrier so you could just
get a bunch of meds at the start of the
game and just sit up there and just heal
without anyone no other player could
even see you right right you sit up
there you'd Win Every Game you uploaded
the video doing that yeah
well because it was like
at race bro
if you didn't do it you have to get this
video out yeah that was I used to sleep
like two or three hours a night edit my
own video like I try and like sometimes
weep as I'm going to sleep but I had no
moisture in my eyes I couldn't cry
you're like [__] grind you were in a
concert hustle to get that stuff out I
didn't have time to think of like oh is
epic gonna like this glitch yeah I mean
the other day like make fix your bugs
you know they ask nicely I'm like fair
enough that's reasonable like they
explain why I'm like I'm waiting for the
laser beam apology video in like two
years sorry I didn't mean it sorry for
hacking your game bro
um but yeah I mean like makes it they
didn't ban me though but I was honestly
scared sometimes they would have do you
play other games outside of the games
you make content around
um I play I still play a little bit of
RuneScape I had a real phase at the
start of this year end of last year I
would say wow classic uh dragonflight
came out the the new expansion I did do
classic burning Crusade for a bit
um I just don't like other people so I
can't read well I guess socially anxious
so I don't like
you know I I ain't beating like Illidan
with like like a couple V bucks or
something you know I'm like I can't just
pay some money
um so yeah like rating like intimidated
me so I didn't I didn't keep playing
what else do I play I'll play still a
little sports games play a lot of
Crusader Kings uh like the strategy
games I love that [__]
um been playing Super Auto pets a lot
lately shout outs mobile games uh what
else do I play
honestly like it's either hardcore
strategy games
I love strategy games or uh yeah quite
literally just playing a sports game of
some kind probably yeah FIFA oh the good
old days man yeah it's really hard to
make videos on strategy games though oh
it's it's really tough but some people
do make some great questions there's
another Aussie who does and he does like
factorio videos oh I haven't seen that
unfortunately it sounds like I'm missing
out and they're really good because
factorio is probably the most boring
[__] game in the world but some
people can make [__] so compelling yeah
they just make it into a good narrative
and it just works I forgot the guy's
name he's very funny
um he just like just cause speed runs
but honestly speed runs are like 70 hour
runs [__] you know in one go insane
humans yeah insane humans actually just
another level of insanity you you
mentioned earlier as well that you know
when you started out maybe you do now
you had imposter syndrome but obviously
right now you're at like it's worse yeah
a high level like does it yeah I mean
how does that come into effect with
slowing down making content or do you
second guess yourself a lot more I think
that is
um I think when you're in a Rhythm
um it's easy to just keep going yeah and
you don't think like you still have
imposter syndrome but like you don't
you're still just in a rhythm yeah yeah
when you sort of take because a bunch of
[__] happened in my life in 2021 that
was sort of the reason to take a step
back yeah yeah um [__] that was outside
my control unfortunately but you know
life's fine now but it sort of broke
that Rhythm a little bit and all of a
sudden when you're out of that Rhythm
you start overthinking videos a little
bit and you're like I know what you mean
I know yeah yeah and then you get like a
eight out of ten or no maybe I'm not as
good as I thought I don't know this is
crazy uh it also just comes down to like
a lot of shit's quite boring in gaming
right now I would say unfortunately
there's nothing that really makes me too
enthusiastic yeah so I feel like if I'm
not fully believing in the video it's
not worth it it's not worth it even
though people just like saying yeah fun
just just do something well it sucks
right because you kind of get that you
kind of get like a false alarm and
because sometimes you get some videos
that just feel so right and it works
perfectly yeah and then you're like damn
but this other video just doesn't just
doesn't feel like that and it's like
well that's what having a job is yeah
yeah not relying on that high of getting
everything perfect it's it's having a
force yourself when the idea is maybe
not as good as it could be to either
make it better or just power through and
make it decent yeah yeah but is that not
like I would say
some of the massive privilege that comes
with like perhaps you have some previous
success oh absolutely and there isn't
that like dual die like when I was
leaving the job site it's like it's this
or I'm have [__] no idea what I'm
doing right yeah you are you are just
whatever it takes whereas now you have
choices
other people's videos I could do this I
could like not upload a video I couldn't
I could not I could honestly not awkward
but I still love it I'm still obsessed
with it so it's like you don't have to
do stuff you don't necessarily want to
do which is massive privilege but it
does lead to that like you know
paralysis like decision paralysis yeah
yeah especially when you start doubting
yourself with like am I as good as I
used to be like well people don't like
me anymore like oh but yeah have you
ever thought about doing things outside
of just like you know gaming videos like
because obviously you do like a lot of
challenges with games right now but you
definitely have like the resources to do
like wild and wacky yeah like you can do
like wow like IRL stuff yeah that's what
like my ignorance unfortunately come
into this like I I knew a lot of you
guys from like I was saying to Alex I'm
like oh they're the anime guys right
and that's like my ignorance I apologize
wrong like there's a lot of like Origins
there but you've like sort of expanded
into other things yeah yeah I think um
definitely like I I mean I I've done
pretty much everything that can be done
like sitting on your computer like yeah
right any sort of react stuff stream and
gaming whatever it is and like I said
when I was doing real world stuff it was
very more Vlog style yeah but I think it
is definitely like a goal of mine this
year especially I've done a lot of stuff
with the sidemen who do a lot of like
all they do is yeah that's crazy yeah
all they do is the real world stuff and
I think it's just it's just fun I'm like
I don't really care okay
like I've been there done that when it
comes to getting views it's not really
about that I suppose yeah yeah filming
now it'd just be cool I think it'd be
cool little thing to see so I'm
definitely trying but we'll see yeah
because I feel like they're I I don't
know there's a feel I feel like you
would be so entertaining to do to see
you guys just like see you just doing
challenges IRL instead of just maybe
instead of bullying kids it's funny
though
I had an idea
it was a YouTube show because I didn't
know how to thumbnail but it's like
someone kills me in fortnite shop at the
house
and statistically they're probably like
15. yeah probably less box and match
fight me IRL there's also a chance I
show up as a big bikie or something yeah
yeah kills me which would be equally
entertaining no not for me not for me
though do you think you're gonna be a
good dad oh I'm an amazing Uncle so I
think I'll be a great person to teach
him hard lessons
I know because like I think I'll spoil
them they'll be they'll be they'll be
the ones bullying the other kids yeah
you just teach them like this is
shocked at the video game you're like no
yeah we got a [__] Peter win right
now oh yeah no so I have my nephew as
part of my most recent Roblox video I
did I gave him ten thousand dollars
worth of Robux
he's he's 10 by the way
I'm not
I'm not let us say it I'm allowed to say
this because he's dad might get mad at
me but anyways for me
um he spent it all within a day
because he just didn't know what the
[__] he had no concept of what it was
actually like money wrong well because
in Roblox like some guy just convinces
you to buy some item that's actually
worth like 50 Robux for like 50 000 or
something yeah and I think he might have
just wasted on one one or two games or
something and yeah you know it was gone
in the day so I'd probably do that I'd
probably just be that's insane I can't
help but they just they feel like you
want to give him 100 now and see how
long it takes yeah it was it was kind of
funny because it was for the video so I
really care yeah but like obviously you
got a little bit of trouble you're
supposed to share it with his sister but
he did it oh
I made anything you got in trouble with
yeah sure I'm sure sure he's got another
10K right
right yeah if I had if I had some left
but it's really hard to buy that many
Robux nothing wrong with spending ten
thousand the fact you didn't share
though yeah I mean big noise I just
don't know how it went that fast he
messaged me because he has a phone now
yeah so messy was like uncle Lenny
what how can I spend these Robux after I
send it to him he's like yeah you can
spend it I was like just go really slow
spend over like a two months or
something like that have fun enjoy
yourself you know buy the things in your
favorite games pay to win do that stuff
that's fine yeah that's gone in the day
did anybody anything substantial
his character I checked his account it's
got nothing interesting on it where did
it go what do you like someone's
probably just messing my God yeah no buy
this like hat for like a million or
something I could have bought one of
those like items on the exchange and
then you could have been like all right
Uncle I've managed to turn the ten
thousand he could be here
I'm a mogul of Roblox I am that's how
all the richest Roblox like people like
made that money because they like traded
Collectibles either that or they make
the games themselves but
um yeah no I'll I'll be I'll be probably
spoiling them I don't know yeah I know
you should teach them a lesson in like
investment I don't know why but yeah
send him bankrupt yeah I wish my uncle
gave me
bankruptcy court now you're actually
correct seven years there has to be a
there has to be a Roblox bankruptcy
manuals like what is your occasion
there's money Tycoon
some of my favorite Real World videos I
did with like are with him like he's an
audience favorite yeah my nephew
um I'll get back to that like just take
him on adventures and like yeah yeah
because this guy this game off topic now
but like kind of like the the one scene
the one and only scene that stands out
to me the most in [__] Yu-Gi-Oh
remember like the original Yu-Gi-Oh
anime yeah
um there's a scene where this is how I
basically learn about stocks basically
uh it's uh I know the scene you're
talking yeah do you know what I'm
talking about I'm glad we're talking
about anime though I've got opinions but
okay okay we'll get inside of it it's uh
so it's like Seto kaiba's like backstory
I think and he has like an adopted dad
who is like I will adopt you but I'm
going to give you one million dollars
and uh if you can turn this into 10
million dollars I will adopt you
yeah and that's it and uh basically Soto
kyber explains basically like
uh how stocks work and companies real
like Yu-Gi-Oh cards being like I I have
a hundred cards in front of me right now
what if I just buy 51 of this company
represents by 51 uh 51 Yu-Gi-Oh cards
and I forced them to give them 10
million dollars that's how stocks work
oh my God what if we do that with Roblox
well let's just I watch you go on cheese
TV as a kid or whatever right I never
remember none of that like I feel like
as a kid like I'll watch Hugo but I
never in took anything that actually
happened no I I don't know I mean
because also you did you play Yu-Gi-Oh
as well as a kid I had the cards but it
pissed me off at the TV show none of the
cards worked the [__] same yeah no
yeah like the TV show broke rules they
would just change the cards you like
playing it yeah I was like this is
[__] okay kuribo [__] sucks why
does he keep using it my favorite thing
about like and I think it was the same
with like Pokemon cards and [__] is you
just like anyone who had a color printer
was just printing off like these
there was times where we had like some
money as a kid and then times we didn't
and the time of Yugo cards were around
we had like nothing so like my mom's
like yeah you can't have any so I had to
lie to kids about oh yeah I got
Grandpa's deck at home
I've got Grandpa's dad
like where's your cards bro what are you
doing same as Beyblades I didn't have a
Beyblade for like four so Mike because
my dad worked at a printing company so
like we had like the best printer oh so
I forced my dad to print out all the
Exodia cards yeah bring that to school
and they'd be like whoa he's got all the
exodius Bro being nine was such a great
time one more time my friends had cars I
really really wanted
[__] okay I'll trade what do you want
for it and he he gave a list of cards he
wanted for all I think it was The
Elemental Heroes or something yeah and
that was the cards and uh so we so I met
up with him I gave him the cards he gave
me the cards and I'm looking at him and
the top one's fine it's legit and as I'm
like moving these cards around all the
names are just in Chinese but not not
not Chinese Chinese they're in like in
like Roma like uh Roman alphabet Chinese
so it's like it's like it's a Chinese
spelled out phonetically in English but
I was like that's pretty funny what the
[__] is this what it is that's a rare
car and I was like what what the hell I
can't read this [__] what car did you
give me and they were like kind of
discolored as well you [__] me give me
my cards back right now like I got my
mum to [__] scream at like her man to
give me the cards back because she
[__] scammed me my dad will beat up
your dad yeah
did you go through a Pokemon card phase
or anything like that uh I yeah I
definitely have Pokemon cards uh I never
like played the card games themselves
though I don't think anyone yeah
not since I've been an adult though like
I know Loki's like loves these Pokemon
cards but I mean all of YouTube got
obsessed oh yeah massively gambling for
Pokemon cards it was the most sanitized
form of gambling ever yeah yeah I mean
it was some good Investments for some
people
um no I never like got super into like
as an adult like I don't have no maybe I
had some sick cars as a kid but too busy
on RuneScape yeah the real thing yeah
but I I wish like I've thought about
going because I
the reason I was bringing up the whole
anime thing right right because it's
because I watched my first anime
recently properly that was Dragon Ball Z
Pokemon yu-gios TV on the morning
cartoons you know yeah but I never
actually like watched them because okay
there was a [__] but I watched my first
anime and I was very proud of myself uh
Alex behind the camera's been trying to
convince me for a very long time watch
Attack on Titan
Fortnight
captain captain Lee Levi's is the goat
yeah um I was just like yeah I just
wanted to share that I watched my first
anime so thank you oh yeah how do you
feel ah no I was sick um I think even
still
because I watched uh I watched the
subtitle version that's what I was told
was the most authentic way yeah yeah
um
like where did my girlfriend out a
little bit because there's a lot of
grunting and stuff like like ah I like
the like this they delay it's just like
money that was a meme it's actually a
word I didn't know that
it's my ignorance oh it's ignorant right
I I I slowly figured out that when they
were saying Nani like what was showing
up
um that was cool that's a cool thing for
me to skip I thought it was just a meme
yeah yeah yeah it was just like everyone
would edit into their videos
I got you oh my God but it's just like
there's so much like even an attack on
Titan not so much the later Seasons but
there's still so much wasted time I
think in anime so there is an old TV
fortnite brain I think yeah oh yeah no
I'm a tick-tocks
wasted in it explain they just spend a
lot of time just like repeating the same
[__] or like just talk about stuff that
I don't think matters but maybe it's
good for like World building or some
[__] but I'm like are you caught up on a
second time yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't
read it though Alex knows what happened
yeah was it was it can was a lot of it
confusing as well because Attack on
Titan is a weird story no I was I've got
it from start all right okay no no I
mean it was It was obviously just like
keeps throwing [__] at you yeah it's
like all of a sudden everything you
thought was real [__] wrong
everything was real wrong it just like
keeps changing the game on you which I
thought was really cool yeah like it
just kept changing the scope it was
getting bigger bigger bigger bigger yeah
well I think attacking Titan is probably
like in my opinion arguably the best
starter anime
Attack on Titan's way better than death
in terms of like well that was the thing
I was gonna ask is like what should you
watch what's what's next I've been told
Demon Slayer but um I wanna honestly
like get a top five of what I should do
next in terms of starter anime chainsaw
man yeah actually actually before before
we get into this what kind of like TV
shows do you like or movies oh I'm a
very broad spectrum uh person in that
regard I don't think I have any the only
thing I don't like is horror um massive
coward scariest movie I've ever watch
was Scary Movie one
you know there's a comedy right yeah
that's why it's [__] bad
um I was like six or seven when I first
watched it and I thought the scream mask
was from that originally yeah
Okay and like that scene was like a dick
that goes through someone's ear or some
[__] oh yeah yeah no okay
oh yeah yeah so yeah I don't like horror
uh otherwise pretty open to anything
well luckily anime isn't that great
actually I mean Attack on Titan gets
pretty [__] wild that's that's
probably a little bit more gory than
horror yeah that's a bit more violent
gory than horror but yeah
anime generally doesn't do horror well
so that's that's a good thing for you it
does it by accident well yeah okay yeah
there's a lot of things that are
horrific but hey actually there are some
like pretty like scary scenes in Attack
on Titan oh yeah exactly God I just
remember like remembering the first
scene remembering seeing that first
Titan oh yeah like okay can we I mean I
don't know you allowed to like talk
about it yeah yeah let's talk about it
well this way and his [__] mum gets
eaten yeah yeah yeah horrified yeah I
had no context what this show was about
yeah everyone's just like watch Attack
on title man okay I'm like okay anime
can't be that metal right yeah that
hardcore it is yeah I thought May Beauty
like sword fighting like gory in that
yeah this man like yours witnessing
childhood trauma like actual real yeah
credit to the people that animated and
stuff because like you see like lifelong
damage being imprinted in this kid as
his mother is slowly dramatically
chomped in half and it turns out Essie's
[__] stepmom that did it or whatever
it was yeah it's like his father's
previous wife or some [__] so what the
[__] yeah what oh my God yeah I remember
the first time seeing like because
Attack on Titan [__] blew up when it
uh first aired from episode one and just
seeing that first like smiling Titan
like the one that eats Aaron's mom that
was like nightmare fuel you know yeah
especially if you see as a kid also the
like the muscles on the butt cheeks of
the Colossal type that was traumatizing
man you saw every fiber in that gluteus
maximum squats bro yeah 100 is it
traumatizing maybe maybe it was a
different kind of thing I I think you'd
like death note I think Death Note you'd
like a lot all right yeah everyone knows
that Alex track these for me please
remind me later death note I feel Death
Note is like not I wouldn't say it's
like the best uh Gateway anime because
unlike attack on time that's like
especially season one where it's like
very easy to understand very easier
because there's a lot of like high
intense action that anyone can get into
it's a lot more like mental and like
psychological battles rather than like
actual physical fights which I think is
like you know no I think I think I think
Death Note is great like the only the
most physical they get death note is
when Ellen light play tennis yeah like I
still think it's a good start around
mate okay it is but it's a different
flavor yeah right like it's I feel it's
a different side of anime that okay you
know it very much exists and it's still
great what do you still like Attack on
Titan off the top of your head what are
some of your favorite movies oh
Monty Python Holy Grail
a free guy because I'm in it
I don't know like see I consume so much
stuff but like [__] if I everywhere
everything all at once Banger
um I had no idea what that movie was
before I saw it but we went to like some
early screening thing before it blew me
away
um yeah I don't know I don't know if I
have like any sort of genre or any type
of thing that like I'm very like average
ass human being in that regard where I
just did love Death Note okay
Brotherhood it's pretty good because
it's very anime I think the first yeah
the first anime I heard of that like I
knew people were watching years ago was
Full Metal out yeah I think it's been
rated by anime fans like the best anime
okay yeah I'm not watching something
that's got more than like a hundred
episodes if it's like one of those like
is it one piece has got like a thousand
yeah one piece not doing that yeah yeah
that's doable that's fun yeah I say
chainsaw man would be pretty good if you
liked it Attack on Titan because that's
only 12 episodes yeah
is very horny there's already so much
grunting how much more horny
right I'm gonna be real like my
girlfriend thought I was watching
something she's like walking like what
is happening you're in the living room
bro the windows anime that was like uh a
guy who just reviewed brothels in
another universe that was like an animal
what's that one called into species
reviewers yeah uh yeah don't uh don't
know one of your girlfriend in the uh
okay what point does it go from animal
uh anime to hand time
r18 anime is that like maybe show
titties or something oh yeah I mean the
one where they review brothels there's
literally just a sex scene okay in it
where one of them sleep with one of the
girls in the brothel yeah and it's just
it's all there it's fully present and it
goes on for like five minutes or
something so we don't actually know what
the line between that's like an
interesting thought I feel that like
I've never had a little finishing that
line further and further further there's
no point where it's like oh it's I don't
even know what it is anymore
tentacle or no tentacle is that the line
for well see because like this I don't
know anything I mean again
no no because there's a lot of anime and
a lot of hentai that uses tentacles but
like it's the difference between like
how it is I guess utilized okay right
because it's like there's a lot of like
very innocent scenes that use tentacles
but like it's the implication of it
might be construed as something sexual
but it's not adherently sexual because
that's that's my ignorance to
unfortunately this like whole sort of
like I guess communities like I've never
really part-took so I only see the memes
yeah sure
um I mean it definitely exists there's a
lot of it I've got I've got some stuff
to watch now you should watch JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure as well you ever heard
of that one no oh you probably like that
I'm sorry it's like a whole world that
I've just I I it was always one of those
things I never wanted to give up to my
friends that like they always ask me to
watch anime I was like this is one of
those things where I'm putting the Line
in the Sand
just because like [__] you you're asking
too much
it's like a personality trait I don't
watch anime arcane
and I was like this shit's stupid well
yeah I agree yeah but what's the
difference they're Moses big big
difference big difference yeah no but
I'm I'm still I'm very much in the same
like field as Yolanda where it's like if
people around me are continuously like
shoving it down my throat being like
watch it watch it watch it it just makes
me not want to watch it yeah yeah I know
definitely I hate it but I look after
watching Attack on Titan like I watched
that in like the space of like four or
five days or something so I just went
through it all uh that was a lot of
episodes that's like attack four like
four seasons I was grinding bro
it was definitely within a week man I
guarantee you you're yeah I I actually
do recommend Death Note you will like
you want good I'm excited
chainsaws if chainsaw man's only 12
episodes that's an easy one oh yeah
you'll fly by like yeah I think the
reason why death not such a good start
running is because right out of the gate
it's just [__] intense no like you
get hooked within the first two web
what's your favorite animes is this like
a debatable topic that like it gets
heated here not really just because we
watch so many that like my favorite
anime changes all the [__] times I
like that mentality you know it's kind
of like asking what your favorite game
is and I'm like well I have let's say
some of your favorites that's yeah
that's fair is it in that watch list
already yeah I was like the brothel one
I'd say like the one that I usually say
to anyone who asks that question is
probably like fully coolly because
that's like that's also a good show I
think to watch it because it's like it's
hipster it's wild as hell and it's only
six episodes and it is just intense from
start to finish but something completely
unique as well I like that yeah I feel
like that was the one thing even just so
Attack on Titan it felt like a story
that they aren't going to tell in some
other sort of medium yeah even just like
like they just you can't make that I
mean I think they did try to make a live
action attack oh yeah I heard her I saw
someone's like a clipping on Tick Tock
someone saying this is the worst thing
ever I love Hunter Hunter which is great
um animation is great I got a pitch I
don't recommend you watch this
immediately okay okay but maybe maybe
okay I mean I mean I'm excited I don't
see it oh this has got me more excited
what's going on here so faint no
yeah specifically Fate Zero okay
um so it's a battle royale so
it is a battle royale anime where uh a
bunch of wizards and mages they summon
like a legendary hero from history to
fight for them that's sick so I love
that like got like Genghis Khan away
yeah yeah yeah so you know use the
people summon like King Arthur that's
[__] man
um
yeah anime what King Arthur is a girl
yeah
Alexander the Great uh you know that's
the first book I ever read was about
Alexander the Great so yeah so a bunch
of like Legendary Heroes from history
and they just [__] battle it out and
it's a mix between like action and just
Mind Games as well uh because everyone's
like playing chess with each other
trying to like you know trying to knock
each other out which sounds so much
better than it is yes no okay
zero is [__] fantastic yeah the
reason why I was screaming no is because
the problem is that after you watch Fate
Zero there's a whole other bunch of
series and spin-offs and it becomes one
of the most complicated fictional
universes
let's just leave it there can you watch
Fate Zero and just leave it at that yeah
yeah for sure you get would I want to
afterwards that's the problem if you get
too into it then you'll be like well
what else is Fate Stay no it's pretty
good yeah I'd say well yeah I'd say like
if you watched if you just watch phase
zero and unlimitably works that's you
could probably understand like 90 of the
unlimited works is good yeah but like if
you want to feel the remaining 10 then
you have to watch like all these other
like spin-off shows and sequels and
prequels and it gets way too there's a
lot of really dark shows as well you
might I don't know do you like more
serious shows
um probably not really I don't like to
feel things I have to go main uh I like
to go brain dead and just be like damn
that's [__] [__] yeah
dude it is unreal that stuff is actually
so true though like I will watch
something so much or if there's a guy
jumping through a Minecraft maze
the fact that like podcast Clips is so
boring now that you have to have a
[__] Subway Surfer thing at the
bottom just otherwise I can't watch it
yeah
it's 15 seconds of my life but I need
something else to entertain me at the
same time when did that become like a
meta for like I don't know but I did um
it was weird I did a video and someone
re-uploaded the entire thing to tick
tock which I don't care about [__] it
yeah reviews but they put rocket League
highlights below it
and it got 20 million views on Tick Tock
Jesus more than it got on YouTube with
just rocket League Clips below it that's
so weird that's a [__] scam I I saw I
saw this uh I saw this one like YouTube
short and it was just like a random
podcast clip or something that I didn't
really give a [__] about uh but what was
so distracting uh was there was this
like mobile game being played at the
bottom where you had to like collect
coins or something Subway Surfer yeah it
was a Subway Surfer it was like the
shittest player of all time he kept
missing every [__] Gem and I was like
that's how you got you engaged I was
like [__] again and I went to like
like I cannot not notice how [__] this
person is at the game gee that worked he
turned a boring ass video into a banger
how many layers are they going to get to
it's just gonna be like everything we're
like [__] Bells going off the whole
time I don't it's so weird because
whenever whenever I see like that video
where it's just like a podcast or a clip
by itself just isn't enough anymore we
need something to like distract the
brain yeah that's like how they had had
to add flashy subtitles yeah everything
which slowly become Japanese TV yeah
which means flashy subtitles you mean
well before when you had a clipster
podcast they wouldn't [__] subtitle
every goddamn word they say yeah but now
it's like every single every word
yeah there's like little icons that pop
up there's like that's literally what we
do yeah yeah we do that for trash day
secrets on how to get views right here I
feel like this one we're just kind of
like hacking the brain well yeah because
like
it like there's a standard for subtitles
already built yeah it's actually like
the most easy to read and legible yeah
yeah and obviously YouTube just throws
it out the window because you're like
well that's a [__] fast enough
do one word at a time pop up blue
animation go I find it interesting
because I know Mr base uses different
subtitles for Tech talk as he does on
YouTube it's like different energies or
different platform like Tick Tock kind
of rejects the hybrid hyper-produced
like way that YouTube shorts work yeah
they're very much like condensed or
original YouTube video I say original
yeah
um but like
actually trying to tell some story or
whatever yeah and it's a little bit more
manufactured it's a little bit more of
like a set narrative set thing whereas
Tick Tock is meant to be more organic
it's people do it in each other it's
people talking to a camera you don't
really see that as much on YouTube
shorts but to literally to the level of
like psychologically changing the text
just so it comes off with a diff like
trying less hard That's like [__]
nuts because and it it obviously makes a
big difference otherwise you wouldn't do
it yeah right yeah this is this is the
new age oh add-on lies this Tick Tock
video why is the subtitles this color
but genuinely it's cool yeah we're
getting to that point where everyone is
making micro adjustments to try and find
the perfect thing to hack your brain
yeah yeah especially on YouTube shorts
because everyone's making the same video
like everyone's just doing the same like
just
screaming at you a lot of it's fake a
lot of it's just complete just garbage
but it just hooks you even if you I I
watch a YouTube show all the way through
I'm like I hated that why did I watch
yeah that was awful but I gave him watch
time you also get recommended like
YouTube shorts that have like no views
and it's just like a kid oh yeah yeah
like this is my wall because it's like
zero yeah all the time why are you
recommending this [__] to me I guess
I've got to give everyone a chance right
yeah it's weird because I feel like
that's the algorithm trying to do
something but like normally you can tell
within I feel like with like YouTube
sorry why am I the [__] test dummy
for people I know I feel like I feel
like everyone's the test dummy I mean a
video has to have zero views at one
point right that's true but uh yeah I
feel like you can tell when a video is
not like I I can like subconsciously
tell within like I say like point five
seconds oh yeah when like a video is
being recommended to me that has no
views at all yeah yeah yeah you can just
tell it's just the tick tock other I'm
just going to be like I know you liked
all these videos but what about this
Samantha left field yeah something
completely different have you been
recommended a lot of like just out of
context like scenes from movies and TV
shows yeah [__] watch them yeah every
Family Guy episode every South Park
episode I think I've rewatched the
entire John work Trilogy through Clips
out of order
yeah
I mean podcast clips of like Theo Von
just saying something stupid just
because like they'll just send me the
same one every time yeah I think I've
seen I've never seen peaky blinders but
I feel like I could recite basically
every major thing has happened yeah I
feel like I could perfectly replicate a
Joe Rogan episode just based off weird
[__] Clips with his guests where they
go like in the Amazon forest there is a
tribeless yeah it's it's the spiritual
energy of the river it actually makes
them Giga charge and then she's like
what am I what am I listening to have
you seen the the the Deep fake slash AI
Rogan Clips where they are fully talking
and the guest is fully talking their
maps are fully moving it sounds
identical to him but the advertising
some product yeah yeah oh they're the
when they were trying to scam people to
buy stuff yeah yeah well it's just yeah
it's fully fake yeah it's like trying oh
it's crazy I like the advertising this
like
and obviously they do usually advertise
like supplements or some sort of thing
but like completely fake ones yeah it's
kind of like fake ads yeah I watched Joe
Rogan explaining Bionicle and that was
good but knowing that it could be used
for
knowing that it could be used for the
various reasons anymore no no it was
like him explaining Bionicles to Jordan
Peterson or something and it was really
funny because I just thought that they
were going at Deep In Depth into
Bionicle law and I just for some reason
I found that funny I guess they're like
he's poked us along right like sure
they've got to go down some [__]
rabbit holes of course yeah look I I
think I when I used to mow Lawns uh my
first job out of school I would listen
podcasts all the time I definitely I
think I listen to
surely at some point I listen to Joe
Rogan one but yeah like yeah yeah I mean
like I feel like his Clips are
inescapable especially I don't know why
it's specifically his Clips whenever
there's some kind of shit's outrageous
guests no it's it's one is like it's
always some kind of [__] conspiracy
going on like the pyramids man like
there's no tools that they could have
had to build them there and did you know
if you measure the base
this is the pyramids it's the actual
circumference of the earth
to within like micro percent degree well
my favorite one is always like so
there's always been writings about the
ancient city of Atlantis that was lost
through time and uh every every every
civilization talked about this and it
disappeared all at the same time even
though there's no no kind of like
evidence or whatever yeah like how many
how many conspiracy theories can we go
through that one's interesting
is interesting because
well it's like
Sahara
no no
like chunks of desert that used to be
Lush yeah you know lots of tropical
water all that sort of stuff it's just
all slowly being eroded and buried by
the way all the water go you'd never be
able to you'd never evaporation bro
where'd all the water go that's like was
in nature
like there used to be like Australia was
underwater or something but no I don't
know I'm just saying it was like I don't
like have they checked all the sand
have they gone through with a metal
detector and seen if they found Atlantis
I don't know man you know Mike and
favorite conspiracy theory Australia
isn't real no yes we were discussing
this I got an internet fights with uh
the kid that kept saying that he's so
funny
no he just like he just says that when
you fly to Australia you're actually
getting drugged and dropped off in New
Zealand and it's just funny when you
actually are and I mean we might not
actually be in Australia I actually had
to think about it for a second we are in
Australia I'm not so overseas right I
love how I love how there's The
Narrative of like oh yeah this giant
island continent is not real right New
Zealand is definitely real yeah we're
all actors yeah
so so did you make a video like calling
him out well these are back in my
reaction days it was like six years ago
right are you reacted to him so we had a
little beef yeah no he just because he
was just chatting so much dumb [__] I
was just going through all these videos
he was just trying to bait for attention
he was just making all these videos just
waffling on about all sorts of random
[__] I think he still does this day and
honestly hopefully he's doing all right
um but you see people every now and then
just pick back up on it like I think
yeah there's been a few channels that
made full dedicated videos to him even
in recent times because he just pops up
on Tick Tock just yeah chatting some
[__]
if anyone just talks a lot of [__]
you'll eventually get noticed say
something controversial have an extreme
opinion and share with as many people as
possible that's how you make money
or was he like I he's today yeah I think
he's just very deadly someone commit to
a character that hard yeah it's it's
like I don't know I I would think out of
context that flat earthers are immune
but obviously they're like a real thing
right yeah where are they
[Music]
that is a whole thing yeah
yeah no I I hope he was meme yeah it's
uh sometimes you don't know it's like is
this guy a character or is he actually
just crazy I can never tell with the
internet anymore from the Flat Earth
there's like some intelligent Flat Earth
that's the thing right that's like
proved they kept accidentally proving
that the Earth was round but they were
like intelligent enough to be able to
set up all these experiments to prove
that the Earth was was round yeah that's
funny it's yeah it's I have no smart
people can be dumb yes definitely yeah
very much so that's why we watch anime
yeah yeah
do we ever recommend uh another what the
starter anime were I feel like we got on
I mean do you want you want super powers
do you want fights I love a good like
someone described uh Attack on Titan to
me I think they were saying like Game of
Thrones in a way in the sense of way
everyone everyone says is it really oh
because I guess like the scope of things
I'm not really sure like the actual
correlation but I guess maybe it's cool
it's very political yeah like oh yeah I
suppose that part yeah that's actually
very true so I love like a good story in
that regard okay good I love Goodwill
building okay okay I love that [__] what
about like uh Trigon stampede
you reckon that'd be a good starter or
probably not starter anime uh I'd sound
under but it's 140 episodes but it is
good yes
slowly get through but it is good if you
some want something that hits fast and
it's just very very easy to get through
uh one punch man oh one punch oh yeah
that's so good okay okay it's basically
about a superhero who trains so [__]
hard where he can kill everything with
one point I think I've played a Roblox
game babe
okay is it always that you should watch
the subtitle version or should is there
sometimes sometimes sometimes the dubs
are actually better than the Japanese
words yeah okay yeah because I feel like
it's a sacrilegious thing no no no no
that's like there's something like it's
because there are you know a while back
there was a lot of shubs sorry a lot of
English dub versions which just weren't
that great okay yeah but there are a lot
that are pretty decent and I think we've
gotten to this point now where no one
[__] cares and just watch whatever
works for you yeah yeah if if you want
to watch a show that has like I think
like a better like it's better
experience in English uh bachano is uh
incredible it's kind of like a Quentin
Tarantino movie interesting uh you might
also like Finland Saga because I think
there was something interesting about
subtitles I found I was actually had to
pay way more attention to what I was
watching yeah yeah you said it just like
oh my God forbid yeah you have to write
the subway surf for [__] at the
bottom it's the same thing as when
you're sitting there watching a show and
you're like oh I've got Twitter alert
yeah you can't do that way like where
you have to you have to actually be home
you should prop up Subway Surfer under
your TV
of someone who set up their whole house
it was like two TVs above each other
just to obviously make fun of them oh
yeah it's just someone doing like a
presentation and then they were like
wait hold on and then they held up
Subway Surfer and carried
[Music]
oh we're [__] doomeday we need to do
that with anime just have a full season
of [__] Attack on Titan except it's
just cropped and just like this is just
Subway Surfers we are doomed as a people
bro
you have some new anime that you can
watch as well yes yeah well when the
World's End you can always hit it up
you'd be like what's the next what's the
direction oh I will I will I mean it
sounds like I'm gonna have a little bit
to get through yeah do you travel do you
travel often last year I definitely did
uh pretty much lived in England for like
three months I'm so sorry
hey I love it I love it every Aussie
loves English I wouldn't want to maybe
live there forever but yeah London's fun
yeah no London was really cool
um I'd never been to Europe or like oh
wow anywhere with like really old
buildings before you know whoa yeah I
was like [__] this is sick I also just
yeah I don't know just very different
energy I kind of like the cold as well
so it was a really cold when I first
went there
um I was doing content there which was
great yeah not for myself but it's
especially get to travel and do content
but also have like off days where you
can kind of like get to do fun stuff oh
yeah in a place with a purpose and I
really enjoy that especially because it
was like we got locked down here for
like two years couldn't travel yeah yeah
yeah I hope the lockdown here was like
not to make it seem like it's the end of
the world it's a good place to be but um
you know when we could travel again it
was yeah it was rough I did a lot of it
I did a lot of it yeah yeah
um would you ever think about coming to
Japan I've been there once really been
there once yes I've been there once and
I went straight to naseco and
snowboarded for like five days
uh obviously you guys have a lot of
experience in Japan and I'm like I've
been there but I have not experienced
the culture I think I landed in Tokyo
went to the airport hotel and then went
straight to like niseka or something
dude
on season is just Australia it was if I
was just speaking like in an Aussie
accent in English to me this is very
helpful but I'm not getting any cultural
experience here or when you come to
Turkey hit us up oh I would love to yeah
I know pretty much everyone I'm friends
with right now is like it's even
separate friend groups is like yeah I
was thinking about Japan this year yeah
about Japan this year I'm like I'd love
to I mean I'm we're also down to going
to nisaco to [__] yeah I definitely
think I've got to get back there that
was the best well it's funny we we had
an episode where we talked about who we
think the worst tourists are in the
world and Joey's like Aussies when they
go skiing
[Laughter]
oh yeah um anything you want to shout
out uh nothing too in particular you can
watch my YouTube videos please if you're
ever buying v-bucks or Robux just saying
use that yeah v-bucks just in the
convenience store oh of course then tell
this cashier this is in Japanese
I did year eight Japanese and my
Japanese teacher literally said speak
English
if you ever go to the Japan they'll like
if you don't know a word you say it like
you say it in that accent and you might
think oh [__] am I being racist but it
makes it easier to understand
but let's go to like uh McDonald's right
it's like a Big Mac
yeah yeah now's a good time hey look at
all these patrons though I bet they use
code laser yeah all of them all they now
will
but uh Hey if you like to support the
show go over to our patreon patreon.com
trash taste also follow us on Twitter
send us your memes on the subreddit and
if you hate that face listen to us on
Spotify and uh yeah thanks Landon for
coming on thanks so much awesome thank
you
[Music]